and I can't along Big Boy if the church
what's happening now business
here we go [__] the weed of debt
is here tonight
[Music]
hold on low oh [__] oh hello so a whole
lot of love tonight [__] we got a
good show uncle Joey's ready for you
[__]
[Music]
I'm gonna give you my love [__]
uncle Joey here Wednesday the 26th of
April you bad [__] you made it
we got a tremendous show for you tonight
we got a tremendous pre-show you know us
going deep deep deep into the murky
waters of [__] doomed
tonight we're like big floor you know
the pink floor I had three different
ones we got three different weeds
we got the earthquake relief we got this
[__] in the sunset whatever sunset a
sherbert or something it's [__] debt
and look at this when you have this in a
container with no label it's all over
but the shot now who do you think gave
me this the one I [__] Jew always
making that [__] we listen we got
enough here for [__] a week and I
gotta back up in the [__] couch you
got another half a pound of two
different types of reefer you know me
but tonight will like beat Floyd three
different ones why cuz that's how we do
it
look what else we got tonight you've
heard of the stars of debt you've heard
of the trunk of the debt this are the
more balls of death you understand me
these are the [__] more balls these
are called berry blasters if you're
thinking about going deep these are the
ones give this the [__] grandma
Mother's Day look at this you take one
of these little more balls
[Music]
oh [__] and as usual the closet that
Philippe is lonely the deep training if
we don't pick up a new shipment so sadly
look at him he's already telling purple
oh [__]
there you go man down man down man down
oh [__] told you it's gonna be a good
night that I done nothing
don't you worry about what's going down
the v18 get off this [__] periscope
now oh [__] the beautiful stars of debt
and gave them up for Lent but let this
over Jesus on the loose so look out
don't leave your windows open there's
one minute you're playing next meeting a
dykon-- you know i still got my soldier
[Music]
like the [__] skinny [__] guy oh
[__] what are you [__] nuts plenty of
life no-parole break out the coffee
medicine and dip the joints in the
formaldehyde tonight it's one of those
type of night scoffs Oh shake for me
girl I wanna be your back door man are
you [__] nuts in 7371 he wanted to be
your back door man what are you [__]
crazy
who talks like that please over here
chocolate debt swinging swing early
token it's time to do a [__] bomb
[Music]
it's a buffet of edibles here tonight
you'd think that'd be three Chinese guys
dressed up as waiters here picking up
dishes but I ain't that type of party
uncle Joey's serving up debt tonight you
understand me
on Fridays and sadly you serve up dick
Sunday through Thursday you serve up
dead you follow me
BAM there you go that's how we're gonna
do this it's time if I said to you
tomorrow
take my hand she'll come with me
oh [__] let's see one of these mop balls
of death these will be on a clown suit
I'm saying look at least they're
blueberries dipped and [__] chocolate
the THC what are you [__] kidding me
uncle Joey no I'm not [__] kidding
you listen
pack your bags clean up the account and
head west they've been telling you that
since you were [__] 3 remember the
move la Luna everybody wants to go to
the moon but nobody wants to wear a
helmet
you don't say that ain't the quartz
right here oh [__] that is you with the
white truck I didn't know who the [__]
you think you're dealing here with Joey
bananas we got a great show for you
tonight
you want do a few more bonnets and then
it's all over but the shouting
but I'm happy you're here this is weak
we're doing everything it's Wednesday
night no I'm saying them you know I
gotta hit a bomb what the [__] is wrong
with you
Wednesday night [__] had some
Cuban food 200 cochinita it's not bad
it's been asthma since 1988 it's what
you get there won't force I has the best
black beans of rice around I like number
25 got nickel papa that's the same
that's his safe as I keep
because he'll with my feet I said it see
that I'm wanted with raisins and
potatoes what you got to do is like like
this special today and cochinita was
because of you or Pepita but it's boiled
potatoes see my mom wouldn't deep fry
the potatoes and then you throw them
back into the pig out of he'll and let
that Cuban gravy get into those [__]
potatoes with the [__] olives
over white rice with some fried but that
is what are you worried Allah's right
Jesus Christ and those bass put the
green olives into like eight pieces so
when you get a green on it and cahal of
it doesn't overpower the frightened
tremendous they're like my little
push-off with mothballs in the stem yes
what's next 25 milligrams of THC wrapped
around an olive
thank you have to denied being [__]
coming soon who needs a martini when you
got an olive dip and [__] chocolate
understand it's a beautiful [__] idea
on the church are you ready for a bong
Italy what the [__] yeah a little Suge
Knight shared on tonight you're ready to
go
[Music]
that's like that's like what's that dude
Apocalypse Now
the father what's the father looks like
Martin Sheen when he comes out of the
jungle and he sees the smoke and the
[__] foot whatever they all Filipino
and Vietnamese Filipino elephants
I'm trying to put the pieces together on
my own
[Music]
boom flea you ready for the fun hit of
death let's go Jew the German tonight oh
[__]
there's the [__] from the one-eyed Jew
he lost in Jew in Hollywood's and he's
been making a comeback
hi sweets whatever the [__] you call
harsh wits wash wits out of it don't
[__] it man you guys know what I'm
talking about oh [__] here we go here we
go with your little leaf ready to go
with the fondant then I'm one get ready
for the bumps to shove my head out there
we go look we do it I'm saying
[Music]
thank you for giving a tip not to inhale
right away
training is what I talk about your
training every day you're gonna be on
the bonnet that you gotta train every
day go to the gym you gotta do push-ups
do everything understand he sweat and
wait till I give him vitamin B here the
next one here this is that was the 18%
but one I'd you only supplied this [__]
they give to [__] Israeli soldiers
but before they send them to Iraq fields
[Music]
the [__] you can get dealing with other
points they Atlanta you think I'm like
some [__] Lutz that's on the corner
in front of his now [__]
what a real deal here this is 1313
Mockingbird Lane you want to show up
come on down pack a lunch [__] you'll
[__] pass out from the [__] bonnet
deck he'll understand even the [__]
light sometime to try and go off in this
smoke [__] you think you're dealing with
him
some [__] hippie and [__] look at me
this is is a sativa the blend is 18%
suck my dick I like the blend here is
[__] you're gonna leave you're
crawling you gotta go to the corner get
two potato tacos from the [__] store
with a little with a fruit swirl we
haven't been there in a while in misses
they sent me an email
[Music]
he's telling me an email via pigeon
giving another speaker an email via
preacher that's how they that's a prison
email [__] yet we all did do those
things I know I had
[Music]
if you're ready for Lee's second bond is
it anyone's ready for it
oh [__] here we go here we go oh you're
gonna do the earthquake wait - that's
the we we're saving it can't be for the
earth can't save for the earthquake if
we smoke it every week
thank you
[Music]
there we go keep it keep it going keep
it going
there you go suck that Mueller take it
out Oh [__] oh right in your face
you understand me
[Music]
that's right [__] training makes
perfect he [__] with you do look a
[__] [__] joints and [__] if you
don't have the mule of death ain't no
[__] [__] filters it's like the
[__] bullet don't like Denzel didn't
tell you that [__] man I'm fighting
now a periscope is [__]
we'll be back in 10 minutes [__]
youtube.com slash Joey did slash see
black Joey Diaz we'll be back you little
dirty bastards thank you for [__]
hanging out ten minutes